monsieur Vincent ledou monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Premier ministre monsieur le
Premier ministre la Grande-Bretagne a
décidé de quitter l'Europe la question
migratoire n'explique pas tout de ce
choix mais elle a sans doute fortement
influencé l'opinion britannique pour
notre région haute-france cette question
trouve ici un nouveau rebondissement
puisque c'est sur son sol que se situe
la frontière britanque carar est
singulier dans toute l'histoire
géopolitique d'une frontière d'un pays
déplacé chez le voisin non pas de
manière autoritaire mais négocié de
d'ouvre à Calais la France devenant dé
facto le bras policier de la politique
migratoire britannique depuis plusieurs
mois derrière son président Xavier
Bertrand la région haute-fance en
appelle à la renégociation des accords
du Touquet aujourd'hui face à cette
nouvelle donne nous vous demandons
solennellement de les dénoncer nous
entendons déjà des voix s'élever pour
nous opposer l'appel d'air que pourrait
provoquer cet acte nous affirmons au
contraire que l'appel d'air a déjà eu
lieu du fait même d'une législation
britannique favorable aux illégaux et
que seule une dénonciation des accords
du touqu sera en mesure de contraindre
le gouvernement britannique à réformer
sa législation nous le devons pour le
calési nous le devons pour Natacha
Bouchard sa mère nous le devons pour les
acteurs économiques nous le devons pour
les peuples migrants qui sont sur place
et dont certains dans des situations
intenables comme ces mineurs isolés
depuis le 24 juin la frontière
ne peut implicitement plus être accalé
êtes-vous prêt monsieur le Premier
ministre à dénoncer ces accords qui ont
vécu et à resituer nos amis britonniques
désormais paystiers comme vous l'avez
précisé dans la perspective du choix
qu'ils ont démocratiquement fait et dont
ils doivent aujourd'hui assumer
pleinement les
conséquences la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de
[Applaudissements]
l'Intérieur oui monsieur le é merci pour
cette question qui permet d'apporter des
précisions utiles sur ce que sont les
accords du touqué sur qui les a signé
sur l'esprit qui a présidé à leur mise
en œuvre et sur les conséquences
qu'auraient leur
dénonciation d'abord les accords du
touqué ne sont pas les seuls accords qui
régissent la relation entre la France et
la Grande-Bretagne pour ce qui concerne
la frontière et le passage des personnes
qu'elles soient migrants ou non c'est
les accords de canterberurry et les
accords du tké qui ont été signés entre
1990 et 2003 qui régissent cette
relation ces accords sur l'idée qu'il y
a des forces de police de part et
d'autres de notre frontière à la fois en
France et en Grande-Bretagne pour
assurer le contrôle et notamment la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
et que la contrepartie de la mise en
place du tunnel sous la Manche suppose
des contrôles renforcés de part et
d'autres un de mes
prédécesseurs a eu une aspiration juste
en 2003 Nicolas Sarkozi de signer ses
accords pourquoi est-ce qu'il a une
aspiration juste faut pas faire de
petitte politiques sur ce sujet faut
regarder les questions telles qu'elles
se présente et ne me reprochez pas de
dire qu'il a eu raison ou alors c'est
que vous considérez qu'il a tort et il a
eu raison pourquoi il a eu raison parce
que si nous n'envoyons pas le signal
face à des organisations de passeurs que
la frontière est infranchissable contenu
de ce qu'est la situation migratoire en
Europe cont tenu de ce qu'est le cynisme
de ces acteurs et cont tenu de ce
qui'est le nombre de migrants qui
cherchent à se rendre en Grande-Bretagne
envoyer le signal qu'on ouvre la
frontière c'est faire en sorte que
demain il n'y ait pas 4400 migrants à
calis mais 10 15000 si c'est ça que vous
voulez alors il faut revenir sur le les
accords du Touquet c'est ce que je ne
veux pas faire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je recevrai les élus de Calais
tout à l'heure pour leur dire le contenu
de ces accords et que je m'exprimerai au
terme de cette rencontre pour dire
quelle est la position du
gouvernement la parole est